au pied de la tour eiffel interloire a
choisi une péniche avec piano et violon
pour une grande opération séduction des
importateurs du monde présent awa une
paresse objectif faire goûter une
sélection de vins de toutes les couleurs
et tous les cépages depuis les coteaux
de sancerre jusqu'à la mer j'ai un
importateur norvégien qui veut m'acheter
début et que je vais rencontrer demain
ce demain sur le salon pour en discuter
un peu plus amplement
ça peut déboucher sur des très bon
marché parce qu'on sait qu'il ya une
vraie demande dans certains pays et donc
ça peut être très important pour un
domaine comme le nôtre les vins de loire
présente un bon rapport qualité prix
pour les acheteurs étrangers ils sont
très différents selon le terroir le
cépage et l'exposition beaucoup de
vignerons se tourne aussi vers la
culture biologique
j'appelle encore qui sont au minimum
lutte raisonnée
et c'est une région qui a beaucoup de
bio dany dynamique
et biologiques
nos volumes et ont été multipliés par
deux et nos chiffres d'affaires par
trois en dix ans et ça ça vient d'une
évidence c'est que nos vins
correspondent exactement à ce que les
consommateurs attendent en particulier
aux états unis
les importateurs ont goûté les vins du
val de loire en regardant couler la
scène et défiler les bateaux mouches les
vins blancs frais vif les rouges à boire
ou à mettre en cave
ils racontent tous l'histoire de leur
terroir et ils plaisent de plus en plus
au monde